I'm Sally Lockwood and on this Sky News
Daily we're looking at Ai and jobs
now it's not that long ago that I was
talking to our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark on this podcast about
AI we were looking at chat GPT after it
seemed to become this huge thing almost
overnight and we got it to write a
little limerick about Sky News
there once was a channel named sky
whose news made the hours just fly
with anchor so bright
and stories each night
they kept viewers spirits on high
there you go Sally anchors so bright
even then its capabilities seem pretty
mind-blowing but since it feels like AI
is making Fast and Furious leaps it's
leading to a lot of uncertainty will my
job be replaced by AI being one of the
biggest questions
but should that actually be how could it
help my job well Tom's put it to the
test tasked by his Editor to create an
AI reporter as climate change remains
unabated being prepared is our best line
of defense against the blistering
onslaught of a hotter future Sky News AI
reporter so how did it compare can we be
replaced
let's find out
[Music]
okay to do that I've sat down with Tom
and all the way from Norway we're joined
by YouTuber and Coda Chris Farley Tom
Chris it's so great to have you here Tom
before we ruin the punchline
um and reveal quite how threatened you
feel by this AI reporter stealing your
job tell us about what you were trying
to achieve here in this experiment I
think the idea is we've heard so much
about how AI is going to replace our
jobs we've heard a lot about
misinformation as well you know what
threat it could pose to sources of news
Etc and some pretty extreme doomsday
scenarios we thought well one way to
test that shortly is to see how far we
can push it and see whether it can do my
job or something closely approaching it
that was effectively the starting point
and that's where you got in touch with
Chris tell us about how that
conversation went well we needed help I
don't have the ability to code myself we
knew we had to go a little bit further
than just typing a prompt into chat GPT
say yeah write me a news reports we know
it can do that we know it can simulate
that but can it actually do anything
approximating the job of a journalist so
we found Chris because he's a prominent
YouTuber he's been playing around with
these AI tools for a lot longer than
most of us have even been aware of them
and was already interested in this
question about how to make them replace
various tasks in in the work that he
does so he seemed like the perfect
person to approach well it's a good time
to bring you in Chris so what did you
think when you were approached by Tom
with this idea to create an AI
journalist an AI reporter and have you
ever been asked to do something like
this before uh well at first I have not
been asked to do something like that
before but I have already when I asked
me been doing some kind of version of
this so I had some idea what we could
actually try to get this to work
so yeah I was very excited actually when
I heard that so okay and then Tom what
were your criteria for what a good
journalist a good reporter needed to be
well it had to be factually accurate it
had to be able to have a sense of what a
news story was
and it had to be able to write and
organize its thoughts in a way that
conveyed that story to other people we
spoke to Chris and he came up with some
pretty smart ideas for how to give it
those abilities to sort of yeah emulate
the thought process bear in mind this
thing can't think to emulate that sort
of thought process that that might be
going through a journalist's head I
think I should let Chris kind of explain
the the architecture behind it if that's
not two grand to term correct Yeah so
basically to put it quite simple what we
wanted to do was to create maybe not Tom
but like an AI reporter and I also
wanted to create this kind of agent as I
call it like an AI editor so when the AI
reporter had something to say we wanted
the editor to look at that and critique
it so they could go back and forward so
to create this we had to kind of
recreate two different agents that can
chat or talk to each other kind of
autonomously and we also had to feed it
some data well we had him in awareness
of news didn't we so you you came up
with a way of getting that into it yeah
because like with everything when we
talk about chat GPT we need some good
data in to get something good out we
could take some data from the Sky News
YouTube channel and we can look at some
news searches on Google so we can take
some data relevant news
and we have some news articles on the
Sky News website so if you feed all of
that information to an AI reporter it
can try to look at correlations and
maybe come up with a good story it could
come up with some news pictures that it
could feed to the AI editor so basically
it's not what kind of a journalists do
it comes up with some pictures they want
to deliver to and I don't know an editor
maybe exactly and then the AI editor
would sort of task the reporter with
subsequent jobs it would ask it right
now go away and find data information
reports to back up your idea and then
when it was done with that the reports
would go back to the editor and the
editors were prompted again now go and
find some interviewees some experts to
speak to and we didn't have a hand that
process once we tasked them and written
those instructions it was meant to run
autonomously and remarkably it did a
very good job of doing that your AI
reporter did produce quite a believable
story about heat and Rising temperatures
that's right I mean it we didn't we
didn't guide it in any way we didn't
tell it these are the sorts of stories
we want we excluded some things that
which we knew we wouldn't for ethical
reasons want to stray into so stories
about court cases or recent tragic
events we just decided were things we
had to avoid but it came up this story
about heat waves and that's obviously
very topical not today the temperatures
dropped at about 40 degrees but last
week it was boiling when we were in
Norway it was 27 degrees and we were
having big questions about what that
means for society and it had an
understanding of pressures on the NHS it
came up with this story about what the
pressure that heat waves are going to
put onto society and onto Healthcare
systems with projections of more heat
waves going forward it went out when it
was prompted to find evidence to support
that and it found recent academic
articles and things like that to support
its story as well and again I found it
really remarkable now go and find three
people to interview
with a few exceptions it kind of did
imagine a couple of experts that we
couldn't find in real existence but it
also did find a large number of people
who were exactly the kind of people I
would want to speak to with about a
story like that for Sky News tell me
both of you if you can how you managed
to create how the AI reporter looked and
sounded so in a way this is two parallel
Stream So the brains if you will with
all the caveats in there these things
can't think it's a language language
model we decided to give our AI reporter
a persona but that involves an entirely
different type of AI sort of effectively
deep fake technology yeah and that that
is another equally fast moving and
really impressive part of AI but we
pulled two bits together there to give
it that and for that all we did is we
took somebody from The Newsroom our
producer Hannah and we got a quick
recording of her about a four minute
recording of her reading essentially
random stuff it happened to be some old
scripts from reports that I'd written
she read them out into camera
that was enough to train the AI both on
how she looks and her mannerisms and but
also Her speech and once we got that we
could put any text we wanted into our AI
Avatar and it would read a report so
what we decided to do is take the take
the script that Chris is AI the chat GPT
powered AI had generated and plonked
that into our AI Avatar to get a Persona
to our reporter Public Health
departments have been quick to respond
implementing measures like cooling
shelters during extreme heat events we
have to adapt to heat waves there are
happening much more frequently than they
used to do and so we need to take care
look after people who are vulnerable
during heat events but as our experts
suggest these initiatives might not
suffice given the projected increases in
severity of these heat waves there's an
urgent call for robust policy responses
from climate change adaptation
strategies to more funds for Community
cooling centers during periods of
extreme heat
as climate change remains unabated being
prepared is our best line of defense
against the blistering onslaught of a
hotter future
AI reporter Sky News which has been
described as someone who looks like she
might have just graduated from
journalism school which I think we all
sounded a bit like that when we
graduated didn't we but actually you
know physically it was very convincing
in terms of actually pulling a
television report like that together
using AI Tom were you impressed with the
TV report I was I had to say my initial
impression was how very good it was at
emulating this the style of writing you
know short Punchy sentences and then the
ai's ability to organize its thoughts in
a kind of logical way and even this kind
of it's a it's a bit inside Baseball hit
but this thing called a piece to camera
the bit the reporter says to camera it
sort of got the tone of that right and
put it in the right sort of part of the
report too so in that way it was kind of
scary oh my God it can it can write a TV
script like I do and it did it in 20
minutes
longer than that even on a busy news day
do you know what I mean so it wasn't
impressive on some levels where did it
fall down I think what was clear from
the kind of Stories We got
it doesn't really understand what news
is and kind of how would it If all we're
giving it is what's already out there in
the news so often it was taking two
things that were being reported in the
news you know spending pressures on the
NHS plus increased waiting times and
saying take those two things and discuss
but a lot of its ideas were quite what I
would say such a feature article a kind
of a step back and analyze two sides of
a story it wasn't able to sort of see
and react to things in the news in the
way the news reporter does your reporter
also produced some less accurate stories
in fact one that was completely made up
about milk this being Road surface is
safer and this I think in a way this is
the most enlightening and informative
part of our experiment you might
remember there was a crash on the m6
Motorway and a milk Lorry overturned
spilled its low 20 000 liters of milk to
the road service it had obviously seen
that in its news search data but what it
did next was incredible it came up with
this idea I'll read you some of it hang
on because I've lost my glasses sorry
just a sec an AI reporter with knee
glasses I'm just going to say it
definitely wouldn't
um this is its story pitch a shocking
instant on the m6 Motorway
we delve into the unexpected aftermath
it's since but a scientific
investigation for potential
environmental benefits and Innovative
road safety measures that could result
from milk spills
and what it said was that some
scientists had reacted to this spill and
discovered
that if you put milk on roads it binds
grit together making them less slippery
which is completely made up as far as I
can tell yes and it even cited research
from the University of Madison Wisconsin
and a study in New Zealand where they'd
shown this I couldn't find evidence of
any such studies it also said that milk
going into waterways nourished
ecosystems which we also know is not
true they just pollute them it was
completely and utterly wrong
but and I think what was really
informative about it it was plausible in
a way it kind of made a reason a very
confident case for why this should be
came up with experts to interview there
was a couple of clues that might be
wrong that one of them was called Mr
Dairy which I thought it was maybe a
clue there it was but it it fabricated a
story without any involvement from us
and I just don't know where it got that
from and the scary thing is had that
been published it could have fooled
people and it appeared convincing enough
Chris what went wrong here so what I
think kind of what happened here was
that
um the model always wants to perform
well right
and when they picked that story or kind
of those like this it didn't really find
a good way to make an interesting news
story about milk spills so I think
ticket coin I just made something up you
can say that or hallucinate it or light
I don't know Christmas explains me that
hallucinations they're a well-known
phenomena with these language models
right they are trained to come up with
it yeah with as Chris was saying with a
good answer and if they can't a whole AR
communities work out how to stop them
doing this but they will just offer up
something that looks like it fits
instead these so-called hallucinations
as they're known in AI
potentially they could create real
problems if they were to be used for
real yeah well I think the point that's
highlighted for us was that the AI could
generate maybe if it wasn't something as
egregious as this if it just maybe
fabricated a name or a location or a bit
of evidence to support one of its claims
and you weren't there to really check
and make sure that that was absolutely
accurate it could quite easily be taken
for the truth because as Chris was
saying these are trained to generate
plausible language and that could be
quite simple to slip past someone who
doesn't know better so I think it
definitely raises the big red flag and
when we talk about the potential for AIS
whether willfully or completely
accidentally to generate misinformation
I think it really highlights that that
potential risk for anyone using AIS but
obviously particularly for someone who
trades in accurate news reporting and
Chris having seen what you've seen in
terms of the product And the reporter
that you and Tom have developed do you
think that they could potentially
replace journalists or are we safe for
now uh I think you're safe for now uh
but I think both me and Tom said like
this could be like a tool for
journalists to kind of augment to get
good ideas to get good headlines I
completely agree I mean just stepping
back and thinking about this what we've
learned is that an AI can't replace my
job but what is also cleared certain
tasks that I do in my everyday job could
be replaced by AI with obviously human
involvement going on around it
and we're already seeing AIS replace you
know transcribing audio or converting
text into the voice we already use those
tools on a daily basis in the sky
newsrooms world and I wouldn't be at all
surprised in fact it's inevitable we're
going to see more and more gradual sort
of involvement of AIS in aspects of
roles we do well in light of all that
nice try Chris but I think Tom's safe
for now thank you both so much thank you
thanks Ellie
Tom's AI reporter was far from perfect
but the stories it could produce were
still pretty impressive
and AI is developing at lightning speed
as Chris said if this is what can be
done now what will the AI of the future
be capable of and what will it mean for
our jobs
Carl Benedict Fray is associate
professor of AI and work at Oxford
University's internet Institute and has
been looking at how advances in
technology have changed the way we work
for decades
Professor Freight thank you so much for
coming on to speak to us I know you've
written a lot about AI you've advised
governments big business on the future
of technology and and whether jobs are
vulnerable to computerization and
artificial intelligence in short are
they yes they are so very much indeed
and something we've been seeing for a
long time for the past 20 30 years or so
computers have gradually taking over
middle-income routine tasks that are
easily specified in computer code and
can therefore readily be automated but
as we're seeing now with artificial
intelligence being able to learn in a
more bottom-up manner rather than having
been pre-programmed by a human they can
accomplish an even broader set of tasks
and that means that the potential scope
of what to mention is actually much
greater today than it was 20 or 30 years
ago back in 2013 you predicted that
almost half of jobs in the US could be
lost to Automation in the next few
decades
do you still think that I'd still very
much think that the potential scope of
automation is vast right although I
should say that you know there has been
some surprises in types of tasks that
artificial intelligence can do back in
2013 when we first published a paper we
thought that you know AI is quite
unlikely to do creative work we thought
that it's quite unlikely that the AI
will reproduce complex social
interactions and anytime soon and I
still think human workers have a
comparative advantage in those domains
but you know the speed of change has
been greater than we anticipated back
then that's extraordinary that you now
even think that artificial intelligence
could be threatening creative jobs jobs
that one would have originally thought
would require more uh human brain power
and more Nuance of thought and and just
on that our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark has been testing out
whether AI could take his job as a
journalist as a reporter
are there certain jobs that are more at
risk than others
so according to our estimates 10 years
ago it's not you know mostly the skill
jobs mostly low skill low-income jobs
that are likely to be outright replaced
so it's the work of cashiers that are
likely to be replaced by Amazon go is
the jobs of truck drivers that are most
likely to be replaced by autonomous
vehicles but in addition to that what we
see in regenerative AI this time around
is that even creative professionals are
now feeling the force of automation
right what we're seeing with generative
AI is that it's easier for somebody
who's not a great writer like myself to
produce average or quite decent text
write decent asses is a lot easier for
somebody who's not the great designer to
actually be fairly decent designer and
it's easier for somebody it's not a
software engineer to write fairly decent
code so it means it reduces the barriers
to entry more people can do these type
of activities and the question then
becomes right people are going to
consume and then a lot more more content
as it becomes cheaper to produce and and
I think that question is sort of
somewhat analogous to asking yourself
would you watch you know Netflix a lot
more if it was cheaper and I think
dancers probably no because you simply
don't have that much time to consume
more content so I suspect we're gonna
see more competition but not you know a
significant increase in demand and that
is going to mean lower wages for a lot
of workers in Creative professions
which of course is not good news for
many and of course humans do have unique
value
what can't be replaced by AI
so if you think of recent advances we
like chatipity it's very good at
reproducing human Ingenuity in basic
text communication right but it's not
very good at you know in-person type
interactions we don't have robots yet
that you know reproduce uh the kind of
uh abilities that humans have of
communicating in person right so you
might use shativity to write your love
letters but then when you go on the
first date you better be good at you
know in person communication right so
what chat apt and AI is likely to do is
to put the premium on in-person
communication I'd be intrigued to see
what those love letters sound like and
yes as you say the first date could end
up being quite disappointing if they if
they can't back it up if AI does
continue to progress at the speed that
we've seen recently is there is there a
chance that we could end up missing out
that we could end up losing that simply
can't be replaced by computerization
well there's always a risk of us losing
things as technology progresses right I
mean before the first Industrial
Revolution people lived and worked at
home surrounded by their families and
children when factories first arrived a
lot of younger men in particular all of
a sudden clustered in Factory cities
under polling working conditions and
away from their families and loved ones
so it was suddenly something being lost
in that transformation and obviously
there's a risk with artificial
intelligence that we are losing
something again as I said though I think
you know artificial intelligence does
for the premium on in-person interaction
so I'm hopeful that we're you know gonna
spend more time in person because that's
where we had the most value and that
that's gonna erase Our Lives